get me tent up about 6 30. we've got the
tent put the tent up reserve the space
for Gary's tent and went on got the rest
of the phone and come back up here I was
here for the Queen's funeral
I just feel like a combination there's
an event that's
really happens so I just feel like to be
part of it I think we served with you
know that not all of them could get here
because they're living different parts
of the world different parts of the UK
so in a way it's it's our little way of
saying we're here guys representing you
well we've always watched um from the
weddings to the Jubilee to unfortunately
the Queen's funeral and we just decided
we want to be there we want to be part
of the action and it's time